this is the gigabyte bricks gaming or
the G B - B xi5 G - 760 to give it its
full and thoroughly unappealing title
it's the latest in the line of tiny pcs
from gigabyte put unlike his
predecessors this one packs some serious
gaming horsepower despite only measuring
a minuscule 128 millimetres by a hundred
and fifteen millimeters and with a
height of just under 60 millimetres this
new version of the bricks features a 2.8
gigahertz Core i5 processor and a custom
NVIDIA GTX 760 graphics card with 6
gigabytes of memory at $800 or around
560 pounds without any Ram hard drive or
an OS it certainly isn't cheap and some
sacrifices have been made in order to
cram all that Hardware into such a small
chassis lurid green color scheme aside
the Brix is a handsome unit with a solid
all-metal construction and a reassuring
weight
inside you'll find room for an M SATA
hard drive two RAM slots for up to 16
gigabytes of laptop style ddr3l memory
and a further connection for a regular
2.5 inch hard drive because the Brix
comes bare-bones
you'll need to buy and fit these
yourself but the process is easy enough
for most people to do at home having
space for an M SATA and a 2.5 inch hard
drive means you can easily fit a small
SSD to the M SATA port for your OS and
then buy a cheaper spinning plaited disk
for larger storage we kitted ours out
with one of Kingston's HyperX fury SSDs
and eight gigabyte of ddr3l ram the
front of the brick sports 2 USB 3 ports
and a headphone microphone jack while
ran the back Liz Gigabit Ethernet 2 more
USB 3 sockets plus 2 mini HDMI ports and
mini display ports for driving up to 3
displays at a time there's also a plug
for the laptop style 180 watt power
brick it's slightly disappointing the
power supply isn't integrated but given
what's already crammed into the bricks
it's an understandable sacrifice and
the power brick is relatively small how
well the bricks runs games is affected
in part by the RAM and hard disk you
slot inside with the components we used
and for such a small machine the results
are largely impressive we found that
most games ran around the 1080p60
benchmark when run at medium to high
settings but the machine struggled with
more taxing titles battlefield 4 ran
very well at high settings hitting 51
frames per second while unreal engine
powered BioShock Infinite at high hit 59
frames per second the system really
struggled with Crysis 3 though managing
only 48 frames per second of medium
while Metro last light was unplayable at
high settings only by switching down the
game to normal to the game average
around 60 frames per second those are
still good results for such a small box
though and certainly in line with a
mid-range gaming system however there's
a price premium attached to having all
those components housed in such a small
box and you could certainly build a
comparable full-sized system yourself
for less money you'll also have to put
up with a lot fan noise if you decide to
pick up a bricks even at idle the brick
sees fans are distracting but boot of a
game and they kick into overdrive on a
desk its obnoxiously loud and even if
you tucked it away into a cupboard
you're going to hear it this thing pumps
out a serious amount of heat and it's
clear that the cooling system based on a
copper heatsink sandwich and too little
fans at the side of the case isn't quite
adequate for the hardware in our testing
the GPU core temperature was pushing
over 80 degrees which is very toasty and
sometimes cause the GPU to throttle back
its core and memory speed to compensate
that's a shame because on paper the
bricks gaming would make the ideal
living room PC or steam machine it
performs admirably for its size but
despite its power the bricks is
hamstrung by inadequate cooling here's
hoping the next version can do better
you